why is not a branded movement emerged
against this yet a way for us to stand
together to say yes to equality but no
to over categorizing humans are shutting
down ideas and speech pointing out the
warnings that history has given us this
would provide us strength in numbers
this is a terrific question
yep and you know there I don't know that
this is the right answer at all in it at
the very least it's only a part of the
right answer but I think that many of us
who are most loud at the moment also
have a real aversion to branding and
promotion and self-promotion and such
and you know are doing it insofar as we
feel the need but don't like it at all
and so you know this it might be easier
to get behind to this if it was for you
know a movement as opposed to
individuals but I also don't know you
know none of us are expert in what kind
of logistical thing that would require
so like what but maybe the question is
why hasn't it emerged organically well I
think it is emerging organic okay we
just don't know enough to see it but you
know it doesn't have a chapped jaws has
chopped doesn't it doesn't have haven't
declared a part of the garden autonomous
I don't know if you noticed the sign I
put up I didn't know well this LEDs must
have eaten no so here's what I would say
IDW was clearly partially an answer to
this puzzle
IDW was about figuring out how to
continue to have reasoned discussion on
topics where that was supposed to be
ruled out by these various kafka traps
and it was wildly successful and I
cannot emphasize enough what it was like
to be on stage for example in Vancouver
with jordan peterson and sam harris and
lookout for two consecutive nights at an
audience of 3000 people who you wouldn't
have known they weren't at a rock
concert
if you didn't know who was on stage
except no one's phones were out yeah
right
everyone was wrapped and he's an amazing
they weren't really there for the
question of what is the nature of truth
they were there for something bigger it
was much more movement like it was much
more people interested in the idea of
reasoned discussion in an era of no
reason so in any case
IDW had a part of it I think rebel
wisdom has a part rebel wisdom has been
curating different conversations some of
them don't get along all that well but
nonetheless there's an idea that the
answer to this involves juxtaposing
these things and seeing if you can't get
them to play nice together yeah right
game B was an early version of well
we've got structural problems is there a
way to actually plausibly get from here
to an alternative stable solution that
is wildly more successful at
accomplishing what we claim to want to
accomplish so Jamie wheel has got part
of it apparently he and two of our
friends who will be familiar to some
people listening or starting a podcast
Jordan Hall and Daniel smacking Berger
young along with big think yep so all of
these entities but none of that is a
branding right we can point to these
pockets of such intensely reasonable
discourse that you know when it comes to
disagree with itself I can confront that
and say okay you know can we live with
this this dissonance or must it be
resolved but but in terms of a you know
there is no hashtag Beale I'm equivalent
right but so one thing that I've been
thinking is that all of these thing if
it is in fact true that we are going to
bootstrap our way out of this terrible
predicament rather than just allow the
dumpster fire to happen then probably
all those entities ought to coalesce in
one way or another
and if they can coalesce they're gonna
do it hopefully under a banner right at
some level they are all coalescing by
virtue of the fact that the audience
that is hungry for that kind of
interaction bounces from you know from
the portal to rebel wisdom to Dark Horse
you know it's doing that trick so the
question is what is the overarching
thing and in any
I don't know the answer to it but at
some level if there's a political
dimension here if we are going to try to
save the Republic through a novel plan
that interfaces with our existing
electoral system then maybe that flies
under a banner it occurred to me I don't
have the mug down here but what game B
was before it was game B was the
Emancipation Party might be up there but
in any case the Emancipation Party
that's a decent brand because the point
is it's non-political right it's
non-political Siew was non-political hmm
and so anyway there is room for a
branding I would be up for anything that
caused the various loosely aligned
populations who are following one or the
other of these threads to come together
and say well actually you know what
we've all been sort of separately
preparing for something and it came way
faster than we thought it was going to
so now what are we going to do can we
figure out how to get along
[Music]